boris johnson pledging to donate
vaccines
to poorer countries the question of
course many people will be asking is
when when do you think the uk should
start
donating vaccines to other countries
well thank you sophie for focusing on
this story
obviously these are excess vaccines
beyond those that britain
needs the estimate is that we've got 400
million vaccines coming to britain and a
population only of 65
68 million united states has excess
vaccines probably 200 million excess
vaccines and
the answer to your question is the
sooner the better because a hundred
countries have not had a single
vaccination as the secretary general the
point you then pointed out today and
this isn't just a matter of charity we
know
that where the virus is not contained it
mutates
and therefore poses an ongoing risk in
rich countries as well as poor countries
so
the sooner the better we also need to
make sure that the delivery
systems work properly and this isn't
just a matter of getting the vaccines
especially if you think about the pfizer
vaccine with all the difficulties of
keeping it at very low temperature
the delivery mechanisms need to really
make sure that the vaccines are in good
shape when they reach the front line
one other point if i may in the meantime
we know that the economic effects of
kovid have been absolutely disastrous
some of the poorest people in the world
the un's saying
150 million are forced into extreme
poverty living on less than 1.90 a day
and so i think there is a need for other
measures
than the vaccines which is only one part
of a comprehensive and effective
response to this kobit crisis
i just want to try and pin you down a
bit more than the sooner the better
do you mean by saying the sooner the
better is could it be after every adult
has
been fully vaccinated in the uk after
everyone's received a first dose after
the top nine priority groups
have received their vaccine which is
expected at the end of april
what do you mean by the sooner the
better well i think the sooner the
better
if i may defend that statement i wasn't
dodging the question look there are 65
million british
people even if they will go for the
two-shot
version that's 130 million uh doses
britain's getting 400 million doses and
i haven't got in front of me but the the
nhs will have
the number of doses they've got my point
is we don't need rich countries stocking
up
extra doses we need rich countries to
make sure that they yes they've got to
inoculate their own population they've
got to do the vaccination program
but where they have excess doses they
should get them to other parts of the
world because otherwise after everything
rebound is that only after everyone has
been vaccinated in the uk then
that you would give the service if the
uk is now i mean
for the sake of argument say there are
200 million in the stocks in the uk
you don't need 200 million uh vaccines
for the uk the prime minister says
he wants to get rid of them i'd say
don't wait until you've done every
british person
if indeed you've got 200 million already
and you're going to have 400 million in
the end
at maximum britain's only going to need
130 140 million doses
how concerned are you about vaccine
nationalism we've seen it
in the uk and the u.s has used to talk
about the surpluses there we've also
seen of course
in the eu as well where they've almost
tried to say
that they can't send vaccines elsewhere
until
they give to say so how worried are you
that countries are looking to themselves
first
well countries will inevitably look at
themselves first what i'm worried about
is the lack
of vaccine internationalism as a matter
of
morality but also as a matter of
self-interest it's vital
that this vaccine a program is a global
one not just a local one it may sound
like a cliche
that would not save any of us until all
of us are safe but it happens to be
true and the lack of international
response has been one of the defining
aspects of this covic crisis
not just in respect of the vaccines
where actually there's been
international cooperation in setting up
the kovacs
facility which is designed to make sure
that vaccines are distributed
but also in respect of the economic
response
which has been very weak internationally
with countries paying more in debt than
they spend on their own
health care in the case of 65 poor
countries
it's the lack of vaccine
internationalism that worries me more
and i think that it's inevitable that
countries have governments have a first
duty to their own citizens
but it doesn't do their own citizens any
good if the disease is allowed to run
rampant elsewhere
i'm talking about issues that need
international cooperation there's also
been a big
conference on climate change today the
munich security
uh conference where joe biden was
speaking i just want to play our viewers
a bit of what the
u.s president had to say
we can no longer delay or do the bare
minimum
to address climate change this is a
global
existential crisis
and we'll all suffer we'll all suffer
the consequences if we fail
we have to rapidly accelerate our
commitments to aggressively curb our
emissions
and to hold one another accountable for
meeting our goals
and increasing our ambitions
that's why as president i immediately
rejoined the paris agreement
and as of today the united states is
officially once again a party
to the paris agreement which we helped
put together
we just heard joe biden saying that the
us is rejoining the paris agreement how
important a step is that
i think the big message for british
people to understand is that joe biden
means it
i mean i remember back when i was in
office when he came in
as vice president 2008 he he was on the
climate change issue then and he
immediately knew
that it was a foreign policy issue not
just a domestic policy issue
he has every branch of american
government from
defense right through to housing
thinking about how they can respond to
the crisis
and the fact that the chinese are up for
it that the europeans are up for it
means that we have absolutely no excuse
for not making this low carbon
transition that is so
important for the future not just on the
planet but for the future of all of us
and now i've got to ask you a little bit
about uk domestic politics as well
kirsten
big speech this week build as a
it struggled to cut through a bit would
you say
i think he's making important arguments
a cut through
is not going to be the right test at a
time when
people are focused on the pandemic
they're focused on getting their kids
back to school
you know the the issues that are
absolutely present the important thing
from my point of view as someone who's
been
found it grievous that labor has been
unable to offer an alternative
uh to the government for so long is that
he is
determined to make sure that labor is
not just radical but it's also credible
and that's the key to victory it was the
key to victory in 97 2001 it was a key
to victory in
1964 with harold wilson it was a key in
the in 1945
and it's the drive for labor to be
radical but also
credible that is the real test and he's
laying down the foundations
it's a marathon this not a sprint so i
think it's unfair
uh those who are jumping all over him
after a year in office you say it's a
marathon not a sprint
and some i guess on the left will be
worried that
a government that's seen over a hundred
thousand deaths
of covid the worst hit to our economy
since the great frost of 1709 i think
is still leading the polls
i think that the whole and everyone not
just
whether you're left or right has got to
be worried about the fact that britain
has one of the
highest death tolls per capita in the
world i mean that's obviously
a massive issue for the whole country
but at the same time
people aren't thinking about how they're
going to vote in the next election
i mean i know that everyone loves polls
but i've been around long enough now to
three years before the next election
when the question is how are you going
to vote if there were an election
tomorrow there isn't going to be an
election tomorrow
what counts is whether or not the
foundations are being laid
for labor to be a not just a serious
opposition but a credible party of
government
that can bring change to the country
because in the end that's going to be
the test and all governments and
oppositions are being put to the test by
this crisis
it calls for a different kind of
politics actually if you think about it
because governments have to
work in a very different way and so do
oppositions and i think what really
counts
is the seriousness of purpose about
thinking where is labour going to be in
three or four years time
and not taking hits for the sake of it
on the government in the short term
okay david miliband thank you very much
for being on the program today thank you
thank you very much